AND NBC AUDIO TECHNICIAN LARRY
EDGEWORTH HAS DIES AFTER
CONTRACTING THE VIRUS, HE ALSO
SUFFERED FROM OTHER HEALTH
AILMENTS.
>>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN
TAKING A TOUGHER STANCE, AND HE
TOLD REPORTERS HE’S ALWAYS TAKEN
THE VIRUS SERIOUSLY.
>> THIS IS A PANDEMIC.
I’VE FELT IT WAS A PANDEMIC LONG
BEFORE IT WAS CALLED A PANDEMIC.
HOWARD: BUT A REVIEW OF THE
PRESIDENT’S COMMENTS IN JANUARY,
FEBRUARY AND EARLIER THIS MONTH
SUGGEST OTHERWISE.
>> ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT A
PANDEMIC?
>> NO, NOT AT ALL.
WE HAVE IT UNDER CONTROL.
IT’S ONE PERSON COMING IN FROM
CHINA, AND IT’S GOING TO BE JUST
FINE.
NOW THE DEMOCRATS ARE
POLITICIZING THE CORONAVIRUS.
YOU KNOW THAT, RIGHT?
CORONAVIRUS.
AND THIS IS THEIR NEW HOAX.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> NO, I’M NOT CONCERNED AT ALL.
NO, I’M NOT.
WE’VE DONE A GREAT JOB.
HOWARD: THE PRESIDENT IS NO
LONGER SOFT PEDALING THE MAG
MAGNITUDE OF THIS CRISIS, SAYING
IT COULD LAST UNTIL JULY OR
AUGUST.
>> WE HAVE A PROBLEM THAT A
MONTH AGO NOBODY EVER THOUGHT
ABOUT.
THIS IS A BAD ONE, THIS IS A
VERY BAD ONE.
THIS IS BAD IN THE SENSE THAT
IT’S SO CONTAGIOUS.
HOWARD: AND MANY IN THE MEDIA
WELCOMING THE PRESIDENT’S NEW
AND SHARPER TONE.
>> HE IS BEING THE KIND OF
LEADER THAT PEOPLE NEED WITH HIS
TONE TODAY AND YESTERDAY.
>> THE PRESIDENT’S TONE HAS
CHANGED.
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
SHOULD BE APPLAUDED OR, FRANKLY,
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
EXPECTED TO CONTINUE.
THIS IS WHERE HE SHOULD HAVE
BEEN ALL ALONG.
>> THE PRESIDENT WAS SOBER, HE
ACTUALLY, HE WHAT A PRESIDENT’S
SUPPOSED TO DO, HE DELIVERED THE
BAD NEWS.
HOWARD: JOINING US NOW HERE IN
WASHINGTON IS STEPHANIE GRISHAM,
THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY.
WELCOME, I MAY HAVE TO INTERRUPT
OUR CONVERSATION TO COVER
GOVERNOR CUOMO FOR AT LEAST A
COUPLE MINUTES.
AS I SAID, MANY PEOPLE IN THE
MEDIA ARE WELCOMING, EVEN
PRAISING THE PRESIDENT’S NEW,
MORE AGGRESSIVE TONE.
WHAT CAUSED THE SHIFT?
>> YOU KNOW, I DON’T KNOW THAT
THERE WAS A SHIFT PER SE.
YOU’VE GOT TO REMEMBER THE
PRESIDENT, HE DECLARED A
NATIONAL HEALTH EMERGENCY IN
JANUARY.
HE TOOK HIS DECISIVE ACTION TO
SHUT DOWN THE BORDERS WITH CHINA
VERY, VERY EARLY, AND HE’S TAKEN
MANY BOLD ACTIONS SINCE THEN
INCLUDING SHUTTING DOWN BORDERS
WITH EUROPE.
SO HE HAS ACTED APPROPRIATELY AS
WE HAVE LEARNED AND HAD NEW
DEVELOPMENTS ABOUT THIS VIRUS.
HOWARD: BUT YOU KNOW MANY
PROGRAMS HAVE PLAYED CLIPS
SIMILAR TO WHAT I JUST DID, MANY
HAVE WRITTEN STORIES IN WHICH
THE PRESIDENT SAID THINGS LIKE
WE HAVE TOTALLY GOT IT UNDER
CONTROL.
DON’T TAKE MY WORD FOR IT, IT
SEEMS TO MANY PEOPLE, STEPHANIE,
THAT EARLIER HE WAS NOT WHERE HE
IS TODAY IN TERMS OF THE FULL
SCALE MOBILIZATION.
>> WELL, THE VIRUS, THE VIRUS
WASN’T WHERE IT WAS TODAY AT THE
BEGINNING EITHER.
AND I WOULD ALSO SAY I DON’T
KNOW WHY THE MEDIA HAS TO
CONTINUE TO LOOK BACKWARDS.